Dead Space is a stressful game but if
you're looking to add more quarter salt
to your gaming experience look no
further than this first person mod
designed by reverse engineering gamer
for the original 2008 Dead Space this
mod shifts the perspective to a more in
your face angle and is the end result of
several months of hard work by its
creator on the Nexus mods Page reverse
engineering wrote quote the core of this
mod took a little over five days to
create the fine tuning of this mod is
what took several months to locate
functions compare variables stabilize
pointers write bug-free scripts and play
tests a first person view does heighten
the tension of the classic game although
it does so at the expense of vital
visual information for example you won't
be able to see how much help you have
left on protagonist Isaac Clark's handy
spinal gauge and you'll have to listen
carefully for any Necromorphs hunting
you from Beyond your peripheral vision
the craziest thing about the original
dead space and its list of available
mods is that there is none to replace
enemies with Thomas the Tank Engine that
type of mod is so common for horror
games how has it not been made for DS
2008 in all these years for a more
modern Taste of horror the Dead Space
remake is now out and thankfully only
terrifies you in the traditional
third-person way the game has earned a
critical Acclaim since it launched and
the a motive has hinted at Dead Space 2
getting the Remake treatment next but
hold on tight because we're taking a
sharp left at this corner from Dead
Space to Metroid as part of Nintendo's
recent move to bring its more iconic
Game Boy and Game Boy Advance titles to
its subscription service to Nintendo
switch online the company has announced
a port of Metroid Fusion is on the way
the Classic Game Boy Advance title will
be available for all subscribers
starting Thursday March 9th originally
released in 2002 Metroid Fusion follows
the iconic Bounty Hunter Samus Iran as
she explores the surface of Planet Sr
388 in search of parasite organisms
referred to as X the 2D action game is
commonly regarded as one of the best
entries in the Metroid Series in
gamespot's review of the game we stated
it's extremely responsive controls
terrific graphics and great audio make
fusion easily one of the best action
games on the Game Boy Advance Metroid
Prime fusions surprise announcement
comes hot on the heels of Metroid Prime
remakes revealed last month and
considering Metroid dread is also a
fairly recent entry in the Metroid
series we're crossing our fingers all
this means the long-awaited Metroid
Prime 4 is coming sooner rather than
later hit the comments and let me know
what you're getting into this weekend
and we'll see you next week
thank you
foreign